طيب ثم طابت اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى اخبار
الساعه ونبداها بابرز العلم
هلا الارجنتين وكرواتيا المواجهه مستمره
والشوط الاول ينتهي بهدفين للتانجو مقابل
لا شيء للمنتخب الكرواتي
التورد في حرب اوكرانيا مقلب ايران تدفع
ثمنا باهظا وتعيد حساباتها في كيفيه دعم
روسيا
[موسيقى]
في اسرائيل مشروع يميني يعمل على توسيع
الاستيطان وقتل اي حلم لقيام دوله
فلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه
بريطانيا بين شلل العاصفه الثلجيه
والاضرابات العماليه والحكومه في مازر وفي
جنيف نقاهه بيضاء
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اشبه بنهائي مبكر هذا الذي يدور
حاليا في ملعب بالوسيلا بين منتخبي
الارجنتين وكرواتيا الشوط الاول انتهى
بهدفين للارجنتين الاول حققه ليونيل ميسي
فيراكلات جزاء والثاني حققه اللاعب
بالباريس مقابل لا شيء للمنتخب الكرواتي
مباراه محتدمه وحاسمه يقف فيها ميسي امام
فرصه اخيره ليقود بلاده للفوز بكاس العالم
وحتى ان تصل المباراه الى نهايتها سنتابع
الاجواء المحيطه بجماهير المشجعين
والتوقعات من الدوحه من هناك ليث وزاري
اهلا بك يا ليث خارج الملعب ما هي الاجواء
متصوره شويه
صبايا هون وصل من المغرب قبل ايام وهم
جاؤوا لمشاهده المباراه حتى يتضمنوا من
راح يلعب ضد المغرب المنتخب المغربي متى
وصلتوا انتو تقريبا
[موسيقى]
نعم طيب انتم ليش جايين على مباراه
الارجنتين غريبه
ان نتمكن من نعيش الاجواء كاس العالم
من الساعه 9:00 امس بالليل في الساده
الجنوب نحاول ناخذ سكت مال المغرب
فري بكره انا وصديقتي الحمد لله من امس في
الليل واحنا في الاستاذ اعطونا اليوم
الساعه 11
1 2
3899 شخص الذين دخلوا لمتابعه المباراه
الكثير منهم جاء الى هنا على امل الحصول
على تذكره كما هتان الفتيات الفتيات
المغربيات اللتان وسلطه
المنتخب المغربي على على فرنسا غدا وان
يلتقي مع المنتخب يمكن الارجنتيني لحد هلا
ما بقدر
ان شاء الله
العرب
طريقه طريقه
قال المشجعون هم اللاعب رقم 12 في
المباراه
التشجيع ال ال المنتخب المغربي كانت
خياليه يعني اذكر تماما كل مره كان يلعب
المنتخب المغربي مقابل اي منتخب كانت هناك
الحماس وكان هناك التصفيق والاهازيج
والاغاني المغربيه التي تشجع وهذا جزء من
المباراه جزء كبير نفسي في داخل كل لاعب
من المنتخب المغربي طيب هلا شو راح تعمل
راح تظلكم
فين ده ههه
التذكره لدخول همم وفي حال لا نجد تيكيت
وقعوا تدفعني جوند
ونشوف ما راح يربح البرتغال ومشات ساره يا
فرنسا ان شاء الله مربوحه للمغرب شكرا ليت
بزاري من خارج الملعب وان شاء الله يلاقوا
تذاكر ويدخلوا لنا هذا المباراه اذا خلونا
نذهب الى زغرب من هناك همم متابعه
الجماهير
[تصفيق]
الكرواتيه ااا في زغرب بدايه الشرطه
الثاني طبعا الامل يحدثهم بان يعدلوا هذه
النتيجه اولا ثم يذهبون الى المباراه
النهائيه اما عن طريق هدف ثالث او اكثر او
عن طريق ضربات الجزاء كل ذلك امل
على عاتق مودريتش ميسي ام مودريتش من
سيقود منتخب بلاده الى
المباراه النهائيه هذه الصور الان من
يونسايريس من الارجنتين
الارجنتينيين ايضا ينتظرون كيف ستنتهي هذه
المباراه هدف ثالث ام ستقلب الطاوله
بالتاكيد لا يتمنون ذلك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذا عن المباراه التي يخوضها الفريقان
الان نبقى في اجواء المونديال اسود الاطلس
سيكون عام لديهم موعد اا يوم غد وموعد
للتاريخ في مواجهه المنتخب الفرنسي وتامل
الاسود في مواصله زهيرها من ملاعب قطر من
خلال البحث عن انتهاء تاشيره العبور الى
مباراه النهائيه ومواصله كتابه التاريخ
بعد ما اصبحوا اول منتخب افريقي وعربي
يبلغ المربع الذهبي
تل من النجوم
سيسينا في اقوى الانديه الاوروبيه لكن
القوات المنتخب الفرنسي لن تثني المنتخب
المغربي عن الامام بحظوظه في بلوغ
المبارات النهائيه وفق تاكيدات مدربه وليد
الرجالي
اغاني اغاني
مصريه في نصف نهائي كاس العالم فانها تحمل
ايضا رمزيه كبيره بالنسبه لكثير من لاعبي
المنتخبين الذين تربطهم على قات خاصه سواء
تجاه فرنسا
[موسيقى]
من الرباط مراسل العربيه هذا الزبيري ينضم
الينا الان يعني الشارع المغربي عادل اهلا
بك اولا الشارع المغربي النهائي
مرحبا عادل اهنيك ايضا على هذا الانتصار
المغربي التاريخي الافريقيا وعربيا في
نهايتك كاس العالم الشارع المغربي يرفض
حتى سماع سؤال هل تتوقع هزيمه المنتخب
المغربي امام الفرنسيين يقول المغاربه
بلسان امراه ورجل ان الانتصار غدا سيكون
لاسود الاطلس على حسابي
موجه كبيره عنوان عريض المغاربه يقولون ان
اسود الاطلس غدا سوف يفترسون الديك
الفرنسيه
يرفضون قبول ولا واحد في فيلم ان المنتخب
المغربي سوف ينهزم مستوى الايمان بقدرات
كتيبه وليد الرجراجي وصل مستويات قياسيه
الامه المغربيه بالكامل غدا سوف تتوقف
وراء الشاشات في كل مكان رغم التحذيرات من
امطار غزيره طوفانيه متوقعه غدا ليله في
المغرب ولكن الجميع
من اجل ان ي- يعني يواكب المنتخب المغربي
في نصف نهائي الايمان بكل عناصر المنتخب
المغربي وعلى راسهم الحارس العملاق وبونو
ياسين يعني المعنويات مرتفعه جدا ادوات
التشجيع جرى شراء وهل يوم بشكل كبير وكبير
جدا لم ارى في حياتي هذا الاقبال على شراء
الاقمصه قميصه المنتخب المغربي والاعلام
المغربي وغيرها من هذه الجوي الذي سينطلق
من المغرب
للمشجعين للوصول الى قطر وبالتالي ايضا
الاختلافات في شارع المغربي من يشجع
الوداد وغيره من الانديه كيف هو الوضع
اليوم هذه الاختلافات وين راحت
الاختلافات الكرويه المغربيه المغربيه
تنتهي عندما يتعلق الامر سواء بمشاركه
نادي مغرب مغربي سواء الرجاء او الوداد في
احدى البطولات الافريقيه والان عندما
يتعلق الامر بالمنتخب المغربي لكره القدم
الكل وراء اسود الاطلس هنالك الاف
المشجعين الذين انطلقوا في اكثر من 10
رحلات جويه انطلقت اليوم من مطار مدينه
الدار البيضاء اكبر مطار مغربي في اتجاه
الدوحه هنالك ايضا توافد لكل المغاربه
المتواجدين في الدول الخليجيه هنالك ايضا
توافد للمغاربه من امريكا الشماليه امريكا
وكندا وايضا من الدول الاوروبيه كل
المغاربه في العالم كل من استطاع ان يجد
تذكره طائره ولو لتشجيع المنتخب من خارج
ملعب مباراه الغد فهو اتخذ الى الدوحه
سبيلا المغاربه الان همم يعني يحاولون بكل
الطرق ان يدعم المنتخب المغربي حضوريا في
الملعب حضوريا في لوحه همم عبر الشاشات
ليله الغد الخلافات الرياضيه بين الرجاء
والوداد او غيرهما من انديه البطوله
المغربيه انتهت الان الكل وراء هذا المدرب
وليد الرجراجي الذي اصبح ايقونه مغربيه
جعلت ما لم يكن بالحسبان قبل انطلاق هذا
المونديال الان اصبح الحلم مغربيه
المستحيل لم يعد مغربيا كرويا ممكنا طبعا
فرنسا منتخب كبير بطل كاس العالم لمرتين
المواجهات بين المنتخبين هي شبه متكافئه
انتصارين انتصارين فرنسيين وتعادلين
وانتصار مغربي واحد لم يتواجهها من قبل في
نهايه كاس العالم ولكن نقطه قوه المنتخب
المغربي هي لاعبي الذين يمارسون في الدوري
الفرنسي والدوريات الاوروبيه يعرفون لاعبي
المنتخب الفرنسي وطبعا حارثي المنتخبين
كبير بامكانهما ان يكون حارسين لعارنين
همم فرنسا والمغرب طبعا 90 دقيقه او 120
دقيقه من الاعصاب سوف يعيشها المغاربه
ولكن الجمهور المغربي في الملعب وفي كل
مكان ابهر العالم العربي وافريقيا بنفسه
الطويل في التحفيز في التشجيع يعني جمهور
يتوفر على بطاريات لا تنفذ والان ااه هناك
من يقول ان احد اسباب نجاح تنظيم قطر لهذا
المونديال وهذا الجمهور المغربي الشغوف
الذي يشجع المنتخب المغربي من كل الوسائل
شكرا جزيلا عادل الزبيري مراسل العربيه من
الرباط وان شاء الله مربوحه يوم قد هذه
المباراه ونفرح جميعا بهذا الفوز شكرا
جزيلا
[موسيقى]
نذكركم بان النتيجه حتى الان في مواجهه
الارجنتين وكرواتيا في شوطها الثاني الذي
بدا قبل قليل هدفين مقابل لا شيء الى
المنتخب هل الارجنتيني متابعه هذه الصور
المباشره المشجعين المنتخب الارجنتيني
يتابعون هذه المباراه والامل يدوم ان يكون
الطرف الاخوه في هذه المباراه والطرف
الاخر الذي ينتظر نتيجه الغد بين منتخب
فرنسا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وقع وزير الدفاع السعوديه الامير خالد بن
سلمان مع نظيره البريطانيه اتفاق تعاون
عسكري وقلا وزير الدفاع السعودي في مراسم
من ساحه الخياله في لندن ان الاتفاقيه
تهدف الى تطوير قدرات وزاره الدفاع
السعوديه وتوطين الصناعات العسكريه وتعزيز
الشراكه بين البلدين في المجال العسكري
والدفاع من جانبيه شارع وزير الدفاع
البريطاني الى ان اتفاق التعاون الدفاعي
مع السعوديه ركيزه هامه لمساعدها البلدين
نحو دعم الامن المشترك الاقليمي كما بحث
الجانبان التعاون الثنائي في المجال
العسكري والدفاع في الاضافه الى تطورات
الاوضاع على المستوىين الاقليمي الدولي
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
ايران تواصلوا سياسه الترهيبه احكامهم
بالسجن على مئات المحتاجين وتهديدات
للناشطين في الخارج
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله يزيد وسيل العقوبات على روسيا
وايران في اخر حزمه فرضت بريطانيا عقوبات
على 12 قائدا عسكريا روسيا في ضربات
صاروخيه استهدفت مدن اوكرانيا ومدنيين
بالاضافه الى فرض عقوبه على رجال اعمال
الايرانيين متورطين في انتاج وتوريد
طائرات مسيره عسكريه استخدمت في الحجمات
ذكرت بريطانيا ان الطائرات المسيره
الايرانيه الصنع لعبت دور الرئيسيه في
الهجمات الروسيه التي استهدفت الابرياء
والبنت التحتيه
وقبل فرض هذه العقوبات وصفها وزير
الخارجيه البريطاني في تغريده له عبر
حسابه في تويتر صفقات ايران وروسيا بانها
دنيئه وتهدد الامن العالميه
ولان روسيا تعاني من نقص الحائط في
الامدادات العسكريه اصدرت مصدر دبلوماسي
في الامم المتحده في وقت سابق ان الغرب
على علم بان ايران تعتزم زياده الشحناتها
من الطائرات المسيره والصواريخ الى روسيا
بكميات كبيره
لكن يبدو انا طهران لم تعد ترغب في توبيخ
دولي اكبر بسبب مسياراتها واسلحتها التي
تزود بها روسيا موقع اكسوس الامريكي كشف
ان ايران تعتزم تقليل مدى الصواريخ التي
تزودها لروسيا الى اقل من 300 كيلو متر
خوفا من رد فعل دولي
[موسيقى]
المقابل لان نقلت رويترز عن ثلاثه مسؤولين
امريكيين قولهم ان الاداره الامريكيه تضع
اللمسات الاخيره على خطط لارسال انظمه
صواريخ باتريوت الدفاعيه لاوكرانيا وذلك
في اطار دعم واشنطن مواجهتها هجمات القوات
الروسيه في اراضيها ومن المرجح وابقى
رويترز ان يتم الاعلان عن ارسال المنظومه
هذه او هذا الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
رغم التنديد والتحذير واصل النظام
الايرانيه سياسه التصعيد والترهيب لقمع
الاحتجاجات التي دخلت شهرها الثالث في
البلاد بعد تنفيذ حكم الاعدام الثاني حق
حكم القضاء الايراني في طهران على 400 شخص
بالسجن لمده تصل الى عشر سنوات لمشاركتهم
في رحله
في هذا القرار قرار الحكم على 160 شخصا
بالسجن لمده تتراوح بين خمس وعشر سنوات
وعلى 80 شخص بالسجن من سنتين الى خمس
سنوات او 260 شخصا لمده تصل الى عامين
وفقا ما نقلت وسائل الاعلام
الواجهه الكثير من المحتجين المعتقلين
عقوبه الاعدام بينهم لعب كره القدم
الايرانيه امير نصر ازاداني الذي وردت
معلومات انه معرض للاعدام بسبب احتجاجه
على النظام جاء هذا في تغريده على حساب
الاتحاد الدولي للاعبي كره القدم
المحترفين الذي دعا الى الغاء القرار فورا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
توعد وزير الامن الايرانيه اسمعي الخطيب
بانزال العقاب بحق اي شخص يشارك في
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في ايران في اي مكان
في العالم وفقا وثلاث تسنيم الايراني
[موسيقى]
على واقعي تصاعد التوتر في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه في الاونه الاخيره اكد منسق
الامم المتحده الخاص لعمليه السلامه في
الشرق الاوسط ثور وينزلاند التزامه
بمواصله التعاقد فاعليه مع طرف الصراع
الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي لمعالجه الاوضاع
السلبيه واعادتهم الى مسار الحل السياسي
الفلسطينيه
للشعب الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
وقد دشنا الجيش الاسرائيلي هذا العام اكثر
من 2000 عمليه في الضفه الغربيه خصوصا في
مدينه جنين ونابلس في جنين وحدها قتل اكثر
من 40 فلسطينيا برصاصه اسرائيلي من بينهم
مسلحون واطفال لا يتجاوز عمره احدهم اثني
عشر عاما وفي اخر الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه
قتل الجيش متى فلسطينيتيه في السادسه عشره
من عمرها خلال عمليه عسكريه نفذها الجيش
امس الاثنين في جنين
بموازاه الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه المتواصله
باتت خطه ضمه الضفه الغربيه الاسرائيلي
امرا واقعا في ظل الاتفاقيات الاختلافيه
التي توصل اليها نتنياهو مع احزاب اقصى
يمين حيث سيصبح حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه
مسؤولا عما يسمى بالاداره المدنيه في
الجيش الاسرائيلي فيما سيسيطر اليمين
المتشدد بن طير على حرس الحدود في الضفه
الغربيه وما بين هذا وذاك مررت واشنطن
تحذيرا مسبقا لنا اياه بانها لن تتعاطى مع
وزراء متطرفين محضره من وقع مشاريعهم
وتصرفاتهم
[تصفيق]
مشروع اليمين الاسرائيلي لبناء دوله
المستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه المحتله ومنع
دوله للفلسطينيين اخذ دفعه عمليه ومعنويه
مصادره الاداره المدنيه التابعه للجيش
الاسرائيلي من يد وزير الدفاع واعطائها
لحزب الصهيونيه الدينيه الاستيطانيه
المتطرف لا يضع القطه في حراسه اللبن فقط
وفق مراقبين بل يحول محاولات ضم الضفه
لاسرائيل من زاحفه الى سريعه
للمستوطنين وهي محاوله لاحاله القانون
الاسرائيلي على المستوطنين في المناطق
الفلسطينيه بدون ضمن الحالي لهذا هناك
معارضه قويه من المؤسسات الامنيه لتبيعات
ذلك ميدانيا وقانونيا ودبلوماسيه
خطه العمل لحزب المستوطنين هي تكثيف
البناء الاستيطاني في المستوطنات القائمه
وتحويل اكثر من 70 بؤره شيطانيه عشوائيه
الى مستوطنات تتبناها الحكومه الى جانب
حمله هدم واسعه نطاق للبناء الفلسطيني في
مناطق جيم تمهيدا لضمها ما قد يفجر ازمه
مع الاداره الامريكيه والمجتمع الدولي
فضلا عن تفجير الوضع الميداني اكثر
المرحله القادمه هي مرحله صعبه يركز فيها
اليمين المتطرف الذي سوف يحكم اسرائيل على
على الضم وعلى التهويد في داخل مدينه
القدس وايضا على تشجيع مخططات الظلام
لاسيه مع ان هناك اصوات من الوزراء
القادمين همم ينادون لتشكيل وزاره مختصره
بتهجير الفلسطينيين وفق القانون الدولي لا
سياده الاسرائيل على ضفه الغربيه والقدس
الشرقيه وتسيطر عليها بعمليه قتاليه مؤقته
اي ان وزير الدفاع
يدير الوضع لهذا فان ادخال السيطره
المدنيه للحكومه الرسميه تعني بدء الضم
الفعلي للضفه الغربيه في حكومه متطرفه
يبدو فيها نتنياهو الجناح اليسريه سيشدوا
مشروع الاستيطان انتعاشا وتمددا الى جانب
المعالجه الامنيه الاسرائيليه فقط للقضيه
الفلسطينيه بحيث لا تتسع خريطه الواقع
لقيام دوله فلسطينيه ما قد ينهي حل
الدولتين كما تخشى دوائر استراتيجيه في
اسرائيل اما الى قيام نظام ابارتيد او الى
دوله ثنائيه القوميه زياد حلبي العربيه
الضفه الغربيه المحتله
للحديث اكثر معنا من رام الله عاصمتها
منصور الباحث فيها شان الاسرائيلي سيد
عصمت اهلا بك يعني اليوم حينما نتحدث عن
هذه الخطط هل سيكتب لها النجاح ام ام ثمه
ما يعيقها في الداخل الاسرائيلي قبل تم
التطبيق على الارض رغم ما اشار اليه زياده
حلبي من الدفعه المعنويه التي جرى اخذتها
قبل قليل
في وزاره الشرطه وتحويلها وزاره الامن
الوطني وتحويل الحرس الحدود تحت يعني
صلاحيه بن كبير وايضا ذكرت الاداره
المدنيه لصلاحيه يعني عمليا هناك يعني
بشكل فعلي بدات هذه التشريعات الان لا شيء
او قادر على منع نتنياهم من تنفيذ الضم
صامت للضفه الغربيه وتنفيذ كل الاجنده
اليمنيه التي تستحملها احزاب اليمين هذه
الحكومه بشكل اساسي على هذه الاحزاب
المتطرفه على صهيونيه الدينيه وعلى بن
جرير وبالتالي اي اي دعايه يعني تعارض بين
المصالح والناس يعني انهيار الحكومه لا
يريد
انهار هو يريد هذه الاحزاب لاعطائه حصانه
امام محاكمته وايضا البقاء في الحكم لذلك
ما لم يكن هناك تدخل جدي من الولايات
المتحده من دول في الاقليم وايضا تصدي
ميدان فلسطين ربما
هذا يرفع منسوب التوتر اعتقد لا شيء يمكن
ان يمنعه يعني هل تستطيع همم يعني يستطيع
ان نتنياهو هذه الحكومه الاقدام على دق
هذا المسمار الاخير في نعش قيام الدولهتين
وبالتالي مواجهه المجتمع الدولي
اعتقد انه يستطيع لانه يتنياه لا يؤمن
بحال الدوريتين وكل شركائه في الاتلاف لا
يؤمنون لا يؤمنون بذلك بل حتى غزيه لذلك
تبعات يعني همم سيد عصمه دوليه هو هو يعني
هو يعني الان هذا بالضبط يعني ماذا سيكون
رد فعل الدوري هل سيكون مثل كل مره
الاكتفاء بالاذونات
والتصريحات الناريه وربما الاستنكار ان
يكون هناك خطوات جديه لمعاقبه اسرائيل
وعزلها وعزل على الاقليه هذه الحكومه
واسقاطها هذا يتوقف بشكل كبير على الوقت
في الدوله وفي المقدمه من هو الولايات
المتحده اسرائيل تعمل يعني حساب فقط
للموقف الامريكي ومن ثم لبقيت المواقف
الدوليه لذلك نحن نقول يعني موقف امريكي
جدي يمكن فقط ان يشكل كابح امام نتنياهو
ربما يتوسع من استطاهره
ولكن لا يقطع بشكل نهائي الدوري
لانها لن تتعامل مع المتشددين وحتى
مشاريعهم
هذا لا يكفي هذا لا يكفي نحن استمعنا
الارسال الامريكيه ووضح انها اثرت بمعنى
كان يطالب اسمه تولي وزاره الدفاع ولكن
الموقف الامريكي الرافض منعه من ذلك وقال
نتنياهو صراحه
الولايات المتحده لا تريدك في هذه الوزاره
هذه الوزاره هي الضمانه لاستقرار يعني
امني في المنطقه
مع ايران مع الجبهه الشماليه مع
الفلسطينيين وتريد ان تضمن ان يكون فيها
يعني رجل متزن والاقل يعني قدره على
التواصل معها استراتيجيا ولكن في القضايا
التي العلاقه بالاسطان اعتقد انه سيكون
هناك احتكاك يومي مع الاداره الامريكيه
سيكون هناك نوع من الصدام بين الحكومه
والاداره الامريكيه ولكن همم ما هي
الادوات التي يمكن ان تستخدمها الدوله
الامريكيه هل تقف مثلا ضد اسرائيل في
الامم المتحده هل تمنع عنها مساعدات هل
تمنع عنها اسلحه هجوميه اي مستوى يمكن ان
تصل درجه العقوبات
يمكن تاخذها الوقت المتحده هذا يتوقف عليه
سلوك الاداره اللي عليه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بشكل كبير شكرا جزيلا لسيد
عصمه منصور الباحث في شان الاسرائيلي كنت
معنا من رام الله
[موسيقى]
قبل ان نذهب الى فاصل هدف ثالث للارجنتين
صنعها وميسي وحققه الفريق
[موسيقى]
ولدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
في منتجعات سويسرا الجليد متعه النقاهه
الشتويه واختبار لازمه الغاز
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في تونس بينما توشك الحمله
الانتخابيه في الداخل على النهايه ينطلق
بدايه من الاربعاء الصمت الانتخابيه في
الخارج باعتبار ان عمليه الاختراع في
دوائر الخارج تتواصل على مدار ثلاثه ايام
وفق الرزنامه التي اقرتها الهيئه العامه
العليا المستقله للانتخابات
مع بدايه العد التنازلي لاجراء الاستحقاق
التشريعي الاول بعد الاجراءات الاستثنائيه
في تونس غابت كل المظاهر الانتخابيه او
تكاد و رغم ان الحمله الانتخابيه توشيكو
على النهايه في الداخل فانها لم تشهد
التنافس المعهوده في الانتخابات السابقه
اما المواطنون فقد اختلفت ارائهم بين
مساند للمصار الانتخابيه ورافض له
البلاد
جماعتها وخلتنا نحن في السفر خلت البلاد
فارغه
وكانت اخر خطواتها تامين وصول المواد
الانتخابيه الى مختلف في مراكز الاختراع
في الانتخابات يؤ المتابعون انها ستشكل
حجر الاساس في طبيعه المشهد السياسيه
التونسي مستقبلنا
قد تتغير نسبيا في الساعات القادمه
باعتبار الحماس التي قد تطفو للسطح جرار
عمل بعض المترشحين او هيئه الانتخابات
للتدريب همم لكن همم يبقى الرهان على هذا
الاستحقاق لتحقيق همم المحطه الاخيره في
مشروع رئيس الصعيد
على ان تتم عمليه التصويت على مدى ثلاثه
ايام في الخارج على ان يكون يوم التصويت
في الداخل في السابع عشر من شهر ديسمبر
كانون الاول
مع دخوله في مرحله الانتخابيه في الخارج
والحصار الانتخابات التشريعيه في ثلاث
دوائر فقط من اصل 10 تتواصلوا الحمله
الانتخابيه في الداخل وقد غابت عنها جلو
مظاهر التنافس في اول انتخابات تشريعيه
بعد اقرار الاجراءات الاستثنائيه في
البلاد وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس
[موسيقى]
بريطانيا
يلوح في الافق هو قد يمتد لفتره طويله
السبب اضراب عمال السكك الحديديه في جميع
انحاء المملكه المتحده عمال السكك
الحديديه تركوا وظائفهم
وخاضوا اضرابا متسببين في تعطيل 80% من
حركه نقل القطارات هنا نتحدث عن اليوم
الاول فقط لكن الامر لن يتوقف على اضراب
يوم واحد بل من المرجه ان يمتد لشهر كامل
السبب وراء هذا النظام تراجع المستوى
المعيشي ومطلب المضربين واحد رفع الاجور
ياتي هذا طبعا في وقت سجل فيها التضخم
ارقى من قياسيه في البلاد حيث وصل اعلى
مستوياته خلال واحد 41 عاما لاكثر من احد
10%
حمى الاضطرابات البريطانيه في طريقها
الاجتياح اي قطاعات اخرى وليس فقط قطاع
النقل حيث من المقرر ان يبدا الممرضون
وقوات الحرس الحدود وسائقه سيارات الاسعاف
وعمال البريد الى جانب موظفي قطاعات اخرى
خلال الايام القادمه ما من شانه ان يعطل
جوانب اساسيه في الحياه اليوميه في
بريطانيا الاضرابات وضعت الحكومه في موقف
محرج ماذا فعل الى التفكير في مناقشه
تعبئه الجيش لتوفير الخدمات العامه
الحيويه هذا الشتاء تاتي حمله الاضرابات
هذه في توقيت الحساس من السنه حيث تتزامى
مع فتره اعياد الميلاد ما قد يؤثر ايضا
على موسم الاحتفالات السنويه في البلاد
[موسيقى]
احمد مصطفى الكاتب والصحفيه والمحلل
السياسي ينضم الينا اهلا بك سيدي يعني
لتحدث انه الجيش هذه الخطه التي وضعتها
الحكومه لكن ماذا بيد ريشه هناك حتى يفعله
اكثر لينهي هذه الاضطرابات
وكان بامكاني الحكومه عدم التدخل في
المفاوضات بين
النقابات وادارات الشركات والهيئات
والمصالح لكنها تدخلت بشكل جعل الاتفاق
غير ممكن حتى حين يعني كان ناخذ على سبيل
المثال
التمريض كانوا على وشكله اتفاق يوم الاحد
الماضي ولكن الحكومه ضغطت على هيئه الخدمه
الصحيه الوطنيه
هذا ما حدث ايضا همم في همم
الطرحه التي طرحته همم اداره شركات
القطارات الناقل همم
للعمال بزياده بنسبه 9% لكن همم وزير
المواصلات ماركت وزير الاعمال لتربط
الزياده بتسريحه عماله همم يراها العاملون
في همم السكك الحديده انها تؤثر على
السلامه تدخل الحكومه افشل المفاوضات بين
النقابات وادارات الشركات وبالتالي كان
يمكن للحكومه ان تتفاجا هذا الاضراب هل
بيدها خيار ما الخيار الان الذي يمكن ان
تفعله اذا ما دخلت البلاد في شلل لان هذه
الاضطرابات ليست في قطاع واحد وليست ليوم
واحد
اتصور ان الحكومه همم
تعتقد انها ذكيه بان همم
تركت الامور تصل الى هذا الحاد وهمم هي
بذلك تتصور انها همم ستزيد من غضب
الجماهير في بريطانيا على النقابات وهذا
يفيد هذا انها تربط الحزب المعارض الرئيسي
حزب العمال بانه حزب النقابات وهذا قد
يكسبها مجلس السياسيه لكن المشكله ان هذا
بالفعل قد يضر
بالحكومه في انتخابات عام 2024 هناك عامل
مهم جدا همم
تتخذوا الحكومه مبررا لعدم زياده الاجور
وهو ان ذلك همم سيزيد من التضخم وايضا
سيمثل عبئا على العجز في الميزانيه لكن
هذا تبرير مردود عليه لان القطاع الخاص في
بريطانيا بالفعل زاد الاجور للعاملين فيه
ربما بنسب تقارب النسب
وايضا هناك ارباح الشركات التي لا تغذي
ايضا الضغوط التضخميه في الاقتصاد اذا هذا
المبرر التقنيه الذي تستخدمه الخزانه
العامه البريطانيه ليس همم مقبولا لحد
كبير
هو ناجع لدى النخبه الاقتصاديه باختصار
حتى اقتصاديا ليس مقبولا اقتصاديا لانه
انت بهذا لا تزيل الضغوط التضخميه خاصه
وان الاجور في الحكومه وانقطاع العام لم
تجد منذ يعني بدايه
تقريبا ايضا هناك انخفاض في القيمه
الحقيقيه للاجور ما اعلنه المكتب الاحصاء
الوطني اليوم انها تنخفض باكثر من 4% شكرا
جزيلا يا سيد احمد مصطفى الكاتب الصحفي
انشوده كيوت
انسى
[موسيقى]
بريطانيا التي تسببت بالشبه شلل في البلاد
فقمته الاضرابات طبعا الى سويسرا وتحديدا
جنيف التي تشهد منتجعاتها سياحه بيضاء لكن
قاسيه على ما يبدو هذا الشتاء حيث تراجع
الدرجات الحراره في بعض المدن السويسريه
باقل من معدلاتها هذا في هذا التوقيت من
العام حيث بلغت 27 درجه تحت الصفر وهذا
ينطبق ايضا على الكثير من المدن الاوروبيه
وهو ما يختبر ايضا بدا كفايه مخزونات
الدول من الغاز بواسطه ازمه الطاقه
[موسيقى]
سريعا الى العناوين
هلا ارجنتين وكرواتيا المواجهه تقترب من
نهايتها والنتيجه ثلاثيه نظيفه للارجنتين
التورط في حرب اوكرانيا مكلف في ايران
تدفع ثمن باهظا وتعيد حساباتها في كيفيه
دعم روسيا
[موسيقى]
في اسرائيل يعمل على توسيع الاستيطان وقتل
اي حلما لقيام دوله فلسطينيه في الضفه
الغربيه
بريطانيا بين شلل العاصفه الثلجيه
والاضرابات العماليه الحكومه في مازق وفي
جنيف نقاهه بيضه
شكرا لكم
على راس الساعه
[موسيقى]